GOOD MORNING THE ASSEMBLY
SESSION IS CALLED ORDER CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ACOSTA.
I WE ARE CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO.
BURKE.
CARILLO.
CALDERON.
CARILLO CHAO.
CHAVEZ.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG FRASER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
SKINNER GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY LACKEY.
LET ME.
REMOTE.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SOLACE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TODAY.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WORD.
MR
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR WE ARE IN SESSION
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR CHAMBER TO PLEASE
STAND FOR TODAY'S INVOCATION.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN.
BOB.
REVENUES TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WE'VE ENTERED A TIME OF
UNPRECEDENTED ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR ABUSE AND HARASSMENT.
AS A SOCIETY.
WE CAN NO LONGER TOLERATE
IRRESPONSIBLE ACTS OF ABUSE.
TIMES UP CALL FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
IS OVERDUE.
BUT IT IS HERE.
WHENEVER AND WHEREVER THERE HAS
BEEN INEQUALITY AND ABUSE OF
AUTHORITY.
OUR COLLECTIVE HUMAN SENSIBILITY
HAS SAID TIME'S UP.
OUR COUNTRY'S DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE. WITH AN
ANNOUNCEMENT TO KING GEORGE THE
THIRD DAY.
TIME'S UP.
MAHATMA GANDHI GRACIOUSLY SAID
TO GREET BRITAIN IN NINETEEN
FORTY SIX.
IT IS TIME FOR YOU TO THE.
OUR OWN CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT OF
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND SIXTIES
WITH THING TO RACISM AND
BIGOTRY.
TIME'S UP.
NO MOVEMENT AGAINST
INSTITUTIONALIZED ABUSE IN
INEQUALITY.
HAS BEEN AN EASY PATH.
S. MAHATMA GANDHI ENCOURAGED.
I KNOW I DID FROM MY DEEPEST
CONVICTION.
IS BETTER THAN A YES MERELY
UTTERED TO PLEASE OR WORSE TO
AVOID TROUBLE.
MAHATMA GANDHI WAS TALKING ABOUT
INTEGRITY.
TAKING THE STAND WITH IS NOT
EASY TO DO.
TO ME. WE CAN BE AS SIMPLE IS
ASKING WHAT DO I STAND FOR.
THIS IS A MOVEMENT ASKING IF
EACH TO LOOK INTO THE MIRROR OF
OUR CONSCIENCE.
AND ASSESS OUR PERSONAL
INTEGRITY AND OUR CONVICTIONS.
ARROGANCE AND SELFISHNESS ARE
THE SEEDS OF ABUSE IN
INEQUALITY.
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE. WILL
ALWAYS BE DEFEATS OF HOPE AND
HARMONY.
NOW MORE MEDIA.
LEGISLATIVE WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
WHICH TODAY WILL BE LED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA.
MEMBERS.
DRY HAND OVER YOUR HEART BEGAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE DAY'S JOURNAL.
SOME IS EVER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
JANUARY THIRTIETH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EASILY MET AT SEVEN AM
THE ABA WAUKESHA HAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEVEN SIXTIES RESIDING
SHE PLUGGED ALSO WASN'T THE
DESPERATE VOTER THING MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS.
SINCE SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS AND FOR BONUS OR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC STEINORTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MULLIN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADRIN THIS AREA.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
WHO THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER? THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WOULD BLOOM AND BAKER TO SPEAK
ON IN GERMAN AND MEMBER
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SEVEN I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER ITEM FOURTEEN S. B. FIVE
ANYONE DALY ON TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER ALSO AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM
ELEVEN S. B. TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
BRADFORD TO THE NOT TO FILE THE
CLERK WILL KNOW
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY
PLEASE GIVE HIM YOUR ATTENTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM A MISTER
CALDERON STEPS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME SOME SPECIAL GUESTS
HERE TODAY WE HAVE THE.
ABOUT FIFTY BRIGHT EYED THIRD
GRADERS FROM PHOEBE HEARST
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL FROM THE
CLASSES OF MISTY GARROW AND MISS
BUTTERFIELD'S THEY'RE HERE TODAY
TO LEARN ABOUT THE US STATE
CAPITOL. AND OF COURSE ECLECTIC
RECOGNIZE ALL OF THEM BUT A
SPECIAL RECOGNITION TO VICTORIA
MY THIRD GRADE DOCTOR UP THERE.
WELCOME TO THE STATE CAPITOL
.
MR MEDINA RECOGNIZE FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLINS DOES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE
FEBRUARY SIXTH THROUGH THE TENT.
AS NATIONAL SCHOOL COUNSELING
WE.
NATIONAL SCHOOL COUNSELING WEEK
HIGHLIGHTS THE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT.
THAT SCHOOL COUNSELORS CAN HAVE
IN HELPING STUDENTS ACHIEVE
SCHOOL SUCCESS. AND PLAN FOR A
CAREER.
TODAY IT IS MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE JEFFREY.
A MAN.
IT IS COMMITTED DEDICATED AND
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO HIS
STUDENTS.
A SCHOOL COUNSELOR AT NORTH
TAHOE HIGH SCHOOL. AND THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL COUNSELOR OF THE YEAR.
AS A RESULT OF MISTER DREAMS
PROGRAM.
COLLEGE ENROLLMENT ROSE TO
ALMOST NINETY PERCENT.
AT SCHOOL.
IT CAUGHT THE ATTENTION OF THE
COLLEGE BOARD. AND WAS
RECOGNIZED AS THE GOD STERN.
CAPERTON OPPORTUNITY OR. THE
COLLEGE BOARD MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION FOR HIS
WORK.
ON ACCESS AND EQUITY.
AND IF I CAN REMIND THE MEMBERS
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THE
COUNSELORS DO. IN OUR SCHOOLS
EVERY DAY I WOULD COURTEOUSLY
AND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THEIR
ATTENTION.
THANK YOU.
MR RE WORKED WITH THIS DISTRICT.
TO OBTAIN A GRANT TO FUND. NAY
VINCE'S
A COMPREHENSIVE COLLEGE AND
CAREER. READINESS SOLUTION.
HE'S ALSO THE WRITER OWNER AND
THE FOUNDER. OF THE COUNSELING
HE.
A BLOG THAT FOCUSES ON COUNSELOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY HE SIGNED
NEED AND CREATED ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY. FOR SCHOOL
COUNSELORS IN CALIFORNIA.
TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND THE
AMERICAN SCHOOL COUNSELORS
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL CONFERENCE.
BY CREATING A SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM CALLED THE SCHOOL
COUNSELOR COMMUNITY SCHOLARSHIP.
AND REYES ALMOST TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FIND AND SAID ALMOST
THIRTY SCHOOL COUNSELORS TO THE
NATIONAL CONFERENCE.
MEMBERS IT IS MY HONOR TO SHARE
WITH YOU AND WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. JEFFREY.
CALIFORNIA'S COUNSELOR THE YEAR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES.
I'M HERE TO DO. TODAY TO OF.
INTRODUCE ONE OF OUR NEW IN
TERMS.
MARK ANY COMES FROM THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS.
HE STARTED PLAYING SOFTBALL MORE
THAN A DECADE AGO.
AND THE BASKETBALL BECAME HIS
PASSION.
IS NOW AN ASSISTANT BASKETBALL
COACH AT AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
IT WAS HIS COACH CURRICULUM
SUGGESTS HE APPLY FOR THIS
INTERNSHIP.
MARK WOULD LIKE USING HIS IN
THIS INTERN INTERNSHIP TO
EXPERIENCE NEW OPPORTUNITIES
MEET NEW PEOPLE. AND WOULD LEAD.
TO NEW CONNECTIONS.
HE'S IN OUR OFFICE ON TUESDAYS
AND THURSDAYS.
IN ADDITION TO ALL OF THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
MARK ALSO. DRIES FRUIT MOVER.
EVERYONE PLEASE WELCOME MARK
MARSHALL TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
MAKE HIM A WARM. MEMBER OF OUR
TEAM
WHILE.
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH NINE
SHALL BE PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM TEN THE CLERK WILL
PLEASE READ.
SOME JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER THE MOMENT
OTHERS RELATIVE TO NEW ATACADO
SHOW OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS IN
FEDERAL WATERS OFF SHORE
CALIFORNIA.
CAN I HAVE YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AMONG YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY
CALIFORNIANS FROM NON COASTAL
CITIES AND COASTAL CITIES.
BOTH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
HAVE GATHERED HERE IN SACRAMENTO
TO COLLECTIVELY VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING BY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION.
TODAY THE LEGISLATURE WILL JOIN
A GROWING MULTITUDE OF VOICES
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THE SHORT
SIGHTED PROPOSAL.
THIS BIPARTISAN ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION EXPRESSES THE
LEGISLATURE STRONG AND
UNEQUIVOCAL OPPOSITION TO THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION'S DRAFT
LAND TO OPEN UP. ALL THREE
REGIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA COAST TO
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS LEASING
WHICH HAVE BEEN OFF LIMITS FOR
OVER THREE DECADES.
CALIFORNIA KNOWS THE COST OF
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
FROM THE LARGEST SPILL IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY TAKING PLACE
IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE IN SANTA
BARBARA TO THE MOST RECENT REFER
TO FUEL OIL SPILL. SO MANY
COMMUNITIES HAVE PAID THE PRICE.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL OCEAN
ECONOMIC PROGRAM CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL ECONOMY EMPLOYEES.
FIFTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
PEOPLE.
GENERATES APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT ONE TRILLION AND CREATES
AN ESTIMATED EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIA'S GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT.
THE THREAT AND REALITY OF OIL
SPILLS IMPACTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS EXPLAINS WHY. THE
CONCERN TO EXPAND OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING IS SO STRONG IN THE
STATE.
A RECENT PP I SEE STUDY FOUND
THAT AN OVERWHELMING SIXTY NINE
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS OPPOSED
ADDITIONAL OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING.
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROUD OF OUR
COMMITMENT TO CLEAN AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND THE
PROPOSED DECISION BY THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
IS AN AFFRONT TO OUR VALUES AND
A THREAT TO OUR STATE WIDE
ECONOMY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I
WANNA THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA FROM A UPBRINGING
THIS AJ ARE FORWARD MEMBER SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE FORTY FOUR
OIL SPILLS OF OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND GALLONS.
HAVE OCCURRED IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT INCLUDES A ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND GALLON SPILL
IN SANTA BARBARA AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN.
SIXTY THOUSAND GALLONS IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH IN NINETEEN
NINETY.
AND FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
MARTINEZ IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AND LET'S NOT FORGET THE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE SANTA
BARBARA OIL SPILL THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE EXXON VALDEZ SPILL.
AND MOST RECENTLY THE TWENTY TEN
DEEPWATER HORIZON SPILL THAT
SHOWED US THIS YEAR DESTRUCTIVE
POWER THAT OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION CAN BRING.
THE CALIFORNIA COAST IS MORE
THAN JUST A PLACE WHERE THE LAND
MEETS THE PACIFIC OCEAN IT.
HOUSES HABITATS TEEMING WITH
MARINE LIFE IT SUPPORTS TOURISM
AND RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES IT
IS ONE OF OUR MOST MAJESTIC
RESOURCES AND IT'S AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE. JUST THINK OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE FROM COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE ENJOY OUR COASTAL
AREAS.
AND THIS DEMANDS CONSTANT
VIGILANCE AND POLICIES THAT
EMBODY A SPIRIT OF RESPONSIBLE
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP.
UNFORTUNATELY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T SEE IT
THAT WAY AND IS WILLING TO PUT
ALL OF THAT AT RISK IN SPITE OF.
DECADES OF SPEAKING OUT ON THIS
ISSUE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PARENTHETICALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALSO
CONTEMPLATING REDUCING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
ELSEWHERE SUCH AS THE MOJAVE
DESERT.
CALIFORNIA NOT A PLAYGROUND.
AND THIS IS NOT A GAME.
OUR RESOURCES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE RISK.
AND MUST BE PROTECTED AJ ARE
TWENTY NINE IS OUR STATEMENT TO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. NOT
HERE.
NOT NOW
NOT EVER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I REPRESENT MORE COASTLINE IN
ANY OTHER ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA. MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED MILES.
OUR COASTLINE IS RUGGED MAJESTIC
PRISTINE AND IT NEEDS TO STAY
THAT WAY.
OUR CONNIE RELIES ON THIS
EXTRAORDINARY COAST LINE TO
PROVIDE A HEALTHY COMMERCIAL
FISHING INDUSTRY.
IT BRINGS TOURISTS AND PROVIDES
RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN OUR COASTAL
CITIES DEPEND UPON THIS.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROTECT ITS COASTLINE FROM NEW
DRILLING FOR DECADES.
WE ALREADY UNDERSTAND ACCEPT THE
TRUTH OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WE'VE BEEN A LEADER IN
TRANSITIONING AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS.
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND PROVIDING
INCENTIVES FOR ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY SOURCES.
WE KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE.
PRACTICAL IS CREATED ANEW AND
THRIVING ECONOMY.
THERE WAS NO REASON TO GO BACK
IN TIME.
SINCE THE MID EIGHTIES THERE
HAVE BEEN MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
OIL AND GAS PIPELINE SPILLS
EXPLOSIONS AND INCIDENTS CAUSING
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDREDFIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGES. TWO
HUNDRED INJURY INJURIES IN
NEARLY FIFTY DEATHS.
IT'S NOT JUST THE OIL RIGS IF
THE PIPELINES
SHIPS.
THE TRANSFER OIL FROM SEA TO
SHORT THAT CAN CAUSE DAMAGE.
TO IGNORE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEVASTATION DONE BY OIL SPILLS
AND DISMISS THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF WORKING TOWARDS
INDEPENDENCE FROM FOSSIL FUELS.
IS IRRESPONSIBLE AND WE MUST
FIGHT BACK I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY
NINE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR AND I
THINK THE MEMBER FROM SAN SANTA
BARBARA FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. BECAUSE OUR COASTLINES
DESERVE.
TO BE PROTECTED THEY DESERVE NO
PARTISAN POLITICS.
AND NO GAMES WHEN IT COMES TO.
JURY WE HAVE BEAUTIFUL
COASTLINES NOT ONLY NOW BUT FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
NOW THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
GAVE AN EXEMPTION.
TO FLORIDA.
SAYING THAT FLORIDA WAS.
TO ESSENTIAL THEIR COASTLINES
FOR OUR NAKED OUR ECONOMIC
VITALITY.
SO I THE MESSAGE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR OTHERS YOU
CONSIDERING EXPAND INTO NEW
LEASES OFF CALIFORNIA'S COAST.
WEIRD TEN TIMES BETTER THAN
FLORIDA.
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILES OF COASTLINE WITH
FIVE OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
POPULOUS COUNTIES BORDERING THE
PACIFIC OCEAN.
THE COASTAL ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA CREATE SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
WAGES AND ONE POINT SEVEN
TRILLION. IN THE GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT THAT'S CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE.
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA JOBS ARE DEPENDENT ON
OCEAN RELATED ACTIVITIES.
THE TOGETHER CONTRIBUTE FOURTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO OUR
ECONOMY.
IN ADDITION THERE'S ALL THE
FISHERIES AND RECREATION THAT IS
INCLUDED IN THE ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL FISHING INDUSTRY
FEEDS PEOPLE FROM AROUND THE
WORLD.
SUPPORTING MORE THAN A HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND JOBS AND
GENERATING OVER SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
THIS IS WORTH PROTECTING.
IN ADDITION.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE BEAUTIFUL
ECOLOGICAL DIVERSITY ARE
BEAUTIFUL ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
FROM OUR COASTLINES AND
OTHERWISE.
NOW.
I'VE I'VE HEARD THE ARGUMENT AND
IT'S IMPORTANT ONE THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE OIL ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
WE DO.
BUT CALIFORNIA.
pCOASTLINES ARE NOT GOING TO
MAKE
US INDEPENDENT FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA'S.
COASTLINE ALREADY CONTRIBUTES TO
OUR OIL INDEPENDENCE.
AND IN THE UNITED STATES JUST
THIS WEEK.
THERE WAS A REPORT THAT CAME OUT
THAT SHOWED DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
OF OIL IS SURGING.
THIS YEAR WE WILL HAVE A HIGHER
AVERAGE DOMESTIC OIL PRODUCTION
THAN ANYTIME IN HISTORY IN OUR
COUNTRY.
SO WE DON'T NEED TO EXPAND TO A
NEW LEASES IN ORDER TO HAVE
ECONOMIC INDEPENDENCE OR TO HAVE
OIL INDEPENDENCE WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR COASTLINES.
AND FINALLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE JUST HOW BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR A COURSE COAST LINES
HAVE BEEN FOR DECADES IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR.
THIS BODY.
THIS STATE.
DECIDED IT WAS IMPORTANT HAVE A
MORATORIUM ON ANY NEW LEASES ON
STATE PLANS OFF THE COAST.
THAT WAS A BILL SIGNED BY A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR PASSED WITH
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC VOTES.
THAT'S WHICH IT HAPPENED TODAY.
WE DO NOT NEED TO EXPAND.
NEW LEASES OFFER CALIFORNIA
COASTS.
AND TO THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION I SAY LISTEN TO
US.
LISTEN TO THE ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTION THAT WE ARE MAKING
LISTEN TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTRIBUTION THAT WE ARE MAKING.
NOTICE THAT WE ARE MUCH BETTER
THAN FLORIDA WHEN IT COMES TO
DESERVING COASTLINE PROTECTION.
AND WE GOT THIS IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE TAKING CARE OF OUR COASTS
LEAVE THEM ALONE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
I RESPECTFULLY STAND TO WIN
OPPOSING THIS AJ ARE.
FEBRUARY NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
EIGHTY THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BARRELS WERE SPILLED IN
SANTA BARBARA.
TRAGICALLY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE THOUSAND
BARRELS.
WE'RE SPILLED OFF THE COAST.
AND. DOZENS OF CRIMINAL CHARGES
RESULTED SO YES
THERE IS A RISK.
THAT PARTICULAR COMPANY.
WHO HAS SINCE GONE BANKRUPT?
SIMPLY DID NOT SERVICE THE
PIPELINES DID NOT REPAIR THEM.
SO. HEAVY.
OVERLOOKED HEAVY REGULATION IS%
THE ORDER OF THE DAY IF THERE'S
ANY. DRILLING OFF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST I'M THERE.
NOW.
EVERY TWELVE MONTHS EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND BARRELS OF OIL.
SEE BUT OUT OF THE SEA BED OFF
OF SANTA BARBARA IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA NATURALLY.
THROUGH THE SEA BED.
DRILLING WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE
THE INCREDIBLE PRESSURE AND THE
CP.
THAT WOULD HELP.
ALSO.
UNITED STATES IS NUMBER TEN
IMPROVING OIL RESERVES AND WITH
FRACKING AN OFFSHORE OIL WE CAN
BE A NET EXPORTER.
NOT ONLY BECOMING ENERGY SELF
SUFICIENT BUT MAKING MONEY OFF
OF IT.
WE'RE NUMBER FIVE FOR NATURAL
GAS
WHEN YOU DRILL YOU GET A LOT OF
NATURAL GAS
RIGHT NOW THE UNITED STATES IS
REVERSING OUR NATURAL GAS
COMPRESSION PLANTS.
FROM IMPORT.
TO COMPRESS INTO TO EXPORT.
THAT'S VERY GOOD ECONOMIC NEWS.
THE U. S. NEEDS TO BE SELF
SUFFICIENT.
AND WE CAN SAFELY
ENVIRONMENTALLY.
SAFELY.
DO IT WITH MODERN TECHNOLOGY
SO. MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WANT IT.
MAINLY BECAUSE YOU CAN'T TRUST
SOME OF THE POWERS THAT ARE
ABOVE CALIFORNIA I GOT IT.
BUT. I WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
US.
TO TIGHTEN UP.
ALL OF THE REGULATIONS ON
DRILLING OF ANY KIND INCLUDING
FRACKING.
AND.
THAT WILL SATISFY UP WHERE IF.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION DOES
TRY TO FORCE THIS UPON
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A DEFENSIVE
FALL BACK THAT IS.
PALATABLE HOPEFULLY TO A
MAJORITY IN THIS ROOM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT'S MY TWO CENTS.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IS A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR OF
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
NINE.
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL MARINE
WATERS ARE OUR STATE'S MOST
PRECIOUS RESOURCES IN THIS
RESOLUTION SIGNALS TO CONGRESS
THAT WE ARE PAYING ATTENTION.
THAT WE WILL NOT BE PASSIVE
OBSERVERS
THE PRESIDENT'S ATTEMPTS TO PUT
OUR ENVIRONMENT IN JEOPARDY.
NOW SPEAKER I JOIN HUNDREDS OF
SAN DIEGANS THIS PAST SATURDAY
ON MISSION BEACH IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT TO PROTEST THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE COMING OUT MOTIVATED TO
SEND A SIGNAL TO WASHINGTON
ABOUT HOW OPPOSE THEY ARE TO
THIS EFFORT. NOW KNOW THAT I
THINK IT'S FAIRLY CYNICAL THAT
THERE WAS ONLY ONE PUBLIC
HEARING TO TAKE THE COMMENTS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE ON THIS
PROPOSAL IN OUR ENTIRE STATE
TAPPING LATER TODAY. RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO WHAT'S NOT
ACCESSIBLE TO MY CONSTITUENTS
AND THAT'S WHY THEY RALLIED ON
MISSION BEACH THIS SATURDAY NECK
COUNTY AND ALL OF US TO RAISE
OUR COLLECTIVE VOICE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE HEARD. AT THE
ONE AND ONLY TIME WHEN
INITIATION CARE TO LISTEN TO
THEM ON THIS MOST IMPORTANT OF
PROPOSALS. IS BESET BY MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES THE
I'LL WHY THIS IS SUCH A TERRIBLE
IDEA BUT IT BEARS REPEATING THAT
THIS PARTICULAR EFFORT.
UNDERMINES OUR EFFORTS TO MOVE
TO RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THAT THIS A. DENIES THE SCIENCE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THIS PROPOSAL IS AT
ODDS WITH WHAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WANT WHICH IS TO
PROTECT OUR COASTLINES AND
ATTACKED OUR ENVIRONMENT. SO
AGAIN I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE I THINK
THAT THE. MEMBER FROM SANTA
BARBARA FOR HER LEADERSHIP.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BUT STAND UP
LET'S BE COUNTED AND LET'S GIVE
A VOICE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHO'VE BEEN SHUT OUT BY THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE
ALSO AS A. A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR
OF THIS RESOLUTION WANT TO JOIN
ALL OF MY COSTA COLLEAGUES.
INFORMING THIS A COASTAL WALL
OF RESISTANCE
TO NEW OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING I
WOULD ESPECIALLY WANT TO GIVE AT
THANKS TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
RAMON. FOR US BE IS STANDING UP
AND SPEAKING UP AND SHOWING THAT
THIS IS IN FACT A BIPARTISAN.
RESOLUTION THAT THAT.
IS SUPPORTED BY DEMOCRATS
REPUBLICANS INDEPENDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
JUST IN MY DISTRICT FROM MEN AND
BEACH DOWN THROUGH PALACE VERDES
WE HAD A OUR OIL DRILLING
PROPOSAL IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. IN
HERMOSA BEACH WHERE OVER EIGHTY
PERCENT OF HERMOSA BEACH
CITIZENS.
VOTED AGAINST.
NEW OIL DRILLING IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
YOU DON'T GET TO THOSE KIND OF
NUMBERS EIGHTY PERCENT. WITHOUT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE FACT
THAT.
THAT THE OPPOSITION WAS
SUPPORTED BY THE NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES I INCLUDING
MANHATTAN BEACH AND REDONDO
BEACH SO. I THINK IT'S CLEAR
THAT.
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL PARTIES OF
ALL PARTISAN BACKGROUNDS.
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION SUPPORT.
RESISTING ANY NEW OFFSHORE
DRILLING WE ARE CALIFORNIA AND
WE WILL FIGHT BACK.
TO PROTECT OUR BEAUTIFUL COATS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
WHEN I WAS FIRST ELECTED TO SAY
LEGISLATURE I CAME AND I AND I
CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE ON ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM.
AND INTERNET MEDIA AND SO I'M
NOT GONNA REITERATE ALL THE
FACTS AND ALL THE NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN.
EXPRESS ALREADY BY PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS BUT THE THE IMPACT THAT
THIS WOULD HAVE ON TOURISM WOULD
BE. WOULD BE ENORMOUS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
COME FROM NOT JUST ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY BUT ALL OVER THE WORLD
TO ENJOY A BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE.
AND I DON'T CARE WHETHER YOU'RE
SOMEONE LIKE ME IS GONNA BANDS
WHO SPENDS A LOT OF TIME THE
OCEAN SURFING I WHICH BY THE WAY
THAT'S DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS AND
INDEPENDENTS THAT DON'T WANT TO
SEE THESE DEREK'S. PEOPLE THAT
ARE VISITING OUR STATE THAT ARE
ENJOYING OUR BEACHES IN OUR IN
OUR NATURAL BEAUTY ARE GONNA
WANT TO SEE THESE AND IT'S GONNA
BE A MAJOR IMPACT.
TO TOURISM AYE AS WELL AS ALL
THE OTHER ALL THE ECONOMIES.
THAT ARE CONNECTED TO OUR
COASTLINE AND AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
ISN'T JUST SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
LOOKING ONLY TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN EXPRESSING. HOW WE
FEEL IN TERMS OF HOW THIS
DECISION THAT THEY'VE MADE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT ALL
THOSE COMPANIES THAT WOULD BE
WE?
ARE LOOKING TO POTENTIALLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE
OF THIS SITUATION AND ACTUALLY.
START DRILLING OFF OF OUR COAST
IN FEDERAL WATERS.
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE A GOOD
AYE IF YOU WANNA CONTINUE TO
HAVE A GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE STATE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT. EITHER YOU DO
NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF BECAUSE WE
ARE VERY CLEAR IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY OUT THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT RUNS. OPPOSITE OF OUR
VALUES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE ASK THAT
YOU JOIN US IN PARTNER WITH US
IN OUR STAND OF PROTECTING OUR
COASTLINE AND PROTECTING
SOMETHING THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO SPEAK
SUPPORT OF AJ ARE TWENTY NINE IS
A PROUD CO AUTHOR. I LIKE TO
THINK MY OUR. COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA FOR BRINGING IT
FOR.
I WON'T REPEAT ALL THE THINGS
IT YOU'VE HEARD.
AND ALLOW SIMPLY SAY THIS OUT
YOU KNOW THAT ARE CLOSE LINE IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MAKES
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL.
I LOVE OUT REPRESENTING A
DISTRICT THAT IS COMPLETELY
SURROUNDED BY BAY AND WHILE I DO
NOT HAVE AS MANY MILES OF
SHORELINE IS HAVE BEEN STATED BY
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES. I AM TO A
VISITING THEM AND. THOSE OF MY
DISTRICT AND OUR SMALL CITY OF
RICHMOND WITHOUT TWENTY THREE
MILES OF SHORELINE WE APPRECIATE
WHAT IS PROVIDED FOR US.
HISTORY HAS SHOWN US THE DANGER
THAT WILL COME FROM OFFSHORE
DRILLING A LET US NOT REPEAT THE
MISTAKES OF HISTORY WE KNOW WHAT
HAVOC AND DEVASTATION. OFFSHORE
DRILLING CAN CAUSE
WE'VE SEEN IT AND IT'S OUR JOB
TO STOP IT.
FURTHER WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE LARGELY IN
SUPPORT OF BLOCKING ANY. EFFORT.
TO HAVE OFFSHORE DRILLING AS
MANY AS NINETY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT PROTECTING
OUR COASTLINE. WILD VERY VERY
FEW ARE ASKING FOR DRILLING.
IT'S MY BELIEF THAT OUR JOB
HERE.
IS TO SPEND OUR TIME FIGHTING
FOR BATTLES THAT WILL MAKE
FUTURE GENERATIONS PROUD OF OUR
EFFORTS
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES LET'S MAKE OUR
CONSTITUENTS PROUD. LETS URGE
CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AJ ARE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHABAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES I LIKE TO STAND SUPPORT AJ
ARE TWENTY NINE.
AND THE REASON I'M STANDING
SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE I THINK MANY
TIMES
ON THIS FLOOR HERE WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE.
THE PLUSES AND MINUSES OF AN
ISSUE.
WE KNOW THAT TATTOO TECHNOLOGY
IN OUR SOCIETY WE'RE GOING TO BE
MOVING AWAY FROM.
OIL AS A PRIMARY DRIVER RIGHT
TRANSPORTATION ARE NOW IN OUR
ECONOMY.
BUT THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN IN
THE LIFETIME OF ANYBODY IN THIS
ROOM.
IT'S A PHASE IT OUT PROCESS.
YOU JUST NEED TO LOOK AT THEIR
EVERYTHING IN THIS ROOM TO CHECK
PROBABLY FOR THE TABLES IN HERE
HAS SOME SORT OF PLASTIC AND IT.
IT COMES FROM MORRELL.
A CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE.
A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE WHO MANAGES
RESOURCE IN A VERY RESPONSIBLE
WAY.
AND I APPRECIATE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
HOWEVER THE TRADE OFF.
IS FAR IS CHALLENGING WHAT'S
REALLY BEAUTIFUL ABOUT
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN RAISED IN A
COASTAL COMMUNITY REDONDO BEACH.
AND NOW REPRESENTING NORTH COAST
OF SAN DIEGO.
OUR BEACHES ARE UNIQUE TO THE
WORLD AND WE NEED TO PROTECT
THEM.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT I'M
AGAINST OIL I'M NOT AGAINST ALL
AYE THIEVES THERE'S A PLACE FOR
IT WE'RE GONNA PHASE THAT OUT.
BUT I AM FOR THE HISTORY IN THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
BEACHES AND FOR THAT REASON I
RECOMMEND THAT WE NOT DO THIS.
I THINK THAT.
THE SECOND ISSUE I WOULD LAY
OUT TOO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I SEE THIS IS A STATES RIGHTS
ISSUE.
WE AS A STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
THE RIGHT TO STAND UP AGAINST
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS.
DECIDING WHAT OUR ENVIRONMENTS
LIKE.
YOU KNOW I FIND IT OF OUR PARTY
WAS ABOUT THE VALUE OF THE
STATE'S RIGHTS STANDING UP TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I WANT TO BELIEVES FEDERAL
GOVERNOR'S BASS WHEN IT'S.
SMALLER AND FOCUSED ON THEIR
MISSION. AND I WOULD SAY THE
MISSION OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT TO DEFINING.
THE ECOLOGY AND THE ENVIRONMENT
OF CALIFORNIA.
I RECOMMENDED WE VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF AJ ARE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
LIKE I'VE SAID BEFORE.
I BELIEVE THAT THESE
RESOLUTIONS.
CONGRESS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
ARE INDEED A WASTE OF TIME FOR
THIS BODY.
AND I AND WORTHY OF OUR
ATTENTION.
YOU WANT TO COMMENT.
SPEND YOUR TIME DEBATING ON
FEDERAL ISSUES.
RUN FOR CONGRESS.
IT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE IT CAN BE
DONE AGAIN.
BONDING OUR TIME.
WITH THE NON BINDING RESOLUTION
ON CONGRESS I BELIEVE IS A WASTE
OF TIME.
AND LIKE RESOLUTIONS BEFORE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I CAN TELL THAT YOU.
AS MEMBERS OF THIS BODY.
HAVE NOT TAKEN THE TIME TO CALL
YOUR OVERLAPPING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
BEFORE VOTING ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
IT'S A KIND OF SLACKTIVISM.
YOU JUST SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME HERE. RATHER THAN DOING THE
REAL WORK.
I'M COMMUNICATING WITH YOUR
MEMBER OF CONGRESS DIRECTLY.
IS THAT BECAUSE THAT YOU THINK
IT'S A WASTE OF TIME OR THIS
ISSUE ISN'T WORTH YOUR TIME.
TO ACTUALLY COMMUNICATE WITH
YOUR MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
OR IS IT MAY BE BECAUSE YOU
HAVEN'T DEVELOPED A GOOD ENOUGH
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY RETURN YOUR
CALL.
CALIFORNIA HAS A THREE MILE
LIMIT OF JURISDICTION.
FEDERAL LAW. ONLY HAS CONTROL
OVER BEYOND THOSE THREE MILES IF
THIS WAS A DEBATE OF WHAT TO DO
WITHIN OUR THREE MILE LIMIT.
THEN ABSOLUTELY THIS IS WITHIN
OUR JURISDICTION AND WORTHY OF
OUR TIME.
I UP TO SUCH PLATFORMS IN MY
DISTRICT.
BUT THIS ISN'T THIS ISN'T ABOUT
WHAT'S WITHIN THE JURISDICTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THAT THIS RESOLUTION IS
A RIDICULOUS WASTE OF TIME.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO GET TO THE REAL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE FACING ON THE
LEGISLATIVE DOCKET.
BANNING PLASTIC STRAWS OR HAVING
A SUGAR TAX I GUESS
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT MAYBE THOSE
ARE BAD EXAMPLES TO BE ABLE TO
USE.
MAYBE IF THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
USING OUR TIME FOR THOSE ARE
GOOD ARGUMENTS FOR A PART TIME
LEGISLATURE.
WITH PART TIME PAY.
I WILL NOT BE VOTING FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
OKAY THINK CLEAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN CALIFORNIA
IMPORTS OVER SIXTY FIVE PERCENT
OF OUR OIL AND GAS NEEDS.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THEN OF OIL
AND GAS FOR OUR ENTIRE STATE FOR
TODAY AND FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME.
CALIFORNIA FURTHERMORE HAS SHUT
DOWN ELEVEN REFINERIES SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY REDUCING OUR
CAPACITY FOR PRODUCTION. BY OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
GALLONS PER DAY.
WITH NOW AMONG THE NATION'S
HIGHEST GAS PRICES
WOULD NOW AMONG THE NATION'S
HIGHEST UTILITY PRICES AND TAXES
THAT SEEM TO COME OUT DALY OUT
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRAT RUN
BODY THAT WE STAND AND RIGHT NOW
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. THE
LAST THING WE NEED TO DO IS BE
TELLING CALIFORNIANS THAT THEY
CAN'T ACCESS THEIR OWN OIL AND
GAS THAT BELONGS TO THEM. LET'S
BE VERY CLEAR. THIS OIL AND GAS
IN CALIFORNIA DOES NOT BELONG TO
THIS LEGISLATURE IT DOES NOT
BELONG TO ANY OF THE MEMBERS IN
THIS ROOM ANYMORE THAN IT DOES
TO THE THIRTY NINE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. THAT DEPEND UPON
ENERGY FOR ALL THEIR DAILY NEEDS
TO DRIVE BACK AND FORTH TO WORK
TO USE OUR AIR CONDITIONER TO
KEEP THEIR FOOD CALLED THE
REFRIGERATOR.
NGUYEN.
SOLAR NUCLEAR ALL OF THESE OTHER
ENERGY OPTIONS.
OUR GREAT.
BUT THEY PALE IN COMPARISON
TO WHAT WE ACTUALLY USE.
IN OIL AND GAS THERE'S NO REASON
THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
IMPORTING.
APPROXIMATELY TWO THIRDS OF OUR
ENERGY NEEDS EVERY SINGLE YEAR
WHEN WE HAVE PLENTY IN THE
GROUND RIGHT BELOW US.
IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE STOP.
MEASURES LIKE THIS THAT MAKE
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE AND ARE AN
INJUSTICE TO THE THIRTY NINE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT WE
REPRESENT IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
START USING.
USING IT'S ABOUT TIME WE STARTED
USING OUR OWN RESOURCES FOR OUR
OWN CITIZENS THAT IS WHO THEY
BELONG TO.
I URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS EGR AND
I URGE EVERY CALIFORNIAN TO
SUPPORT.
THE EXTRACTION OF THE OIL AND
GAS THAT BELONGS TO EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIANS.
WE CAN DO THIS CLEANLY.
WE CAN DO THIS SAFELY WE CAN
NEWS AN ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
MATTER AFTER ALL CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE WORLD IN TECHNOLOGY.
WE HAVE THE BEST WORKFORCE IN
THE WORLD AND WE HAVE THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
PUT THAT TECHNOLOGY TO USE.
LET'S EXTRACT THE OIL AND GAS
THAT IS RIGHT BELOW OUR FEET.
IT IS ACROSS OUR ENTIRE STATE.
ONSHORE AND OFFSHORE LET'S DO
CLEANLY SAFELY ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY LET'S GET OFF OF THIS
RELIANCE OF FOREIGN OIL LET'S
STOP EXPORTING OUR DOLLARS IN
OUR JOBS TO OTHER STATES. AND
OTHER NATIONS
LET'S USE OUR OWN RESOURCES THAT
BELONG TO EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THE THIRTY NINE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
SO RICHLY DESERVE THEY HERITAGE
IT'S RIGHT BELOW THEIR FEET.
VOTE NO ON THIS AJ ARE AND LET'S
USE OUR OWN OIL AND GAS FOR OUR
OWN CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DEBATED DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW MOAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THINK YOU. I THINK
TODAY'S DISCUSSION HAS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION BUT MORE
THAN ANYTHING I WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT THIS IS ABOUT PLACING
A VOTE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE SPOKEN. MORE THAN SIXTY
NINE ERCENT ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
HUNDREDS FROM THROUGH OUT
CALIFORNIA ARE HERE. TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS OPEN COMMENT
PERIOD THE ONE HEARING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO HAVE THIS
AFTERNOON. THIS IS RELEVANT THIS
IS MEANINGFUL.
FOR THE MORE THAN FIFTEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN OUR COASTAL ECONOMY. THIS IS
MORE THAN JUST A RESOLUTION.
THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING THEIR
JOBS AND THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE IS MY FATHER
WHO FOR MORE THAN FORTY YEARS
HAS WORKED IN A HOTEL ON THE
COAST.
HE KNOWS WHAT IT IS LIKE.
TO HAVE TO CLOSE THE HOTEL.
TO SEE LESS PEOPLE THERE AND TO
RELY ON INDUSTRY WHERE TIPS ARE
IMPORTANT.
AND WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A ROBUST
ECONOMY SUPPORTING. THE VALUES
OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING OF WHAT
MAKES THIS STATE. AN INCREDIBLE
STATE.
STILL MANY LOSE OUT.
SO TODAY I ASK FOR YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND TO
SAY YES ON BEHALF OF THE MORE
THAN SIXTY NINE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS. ON BOTH SIDES ON
ALL SIDES OF THE AISLE WHO
OPPOSE THIS RESOLUTION WHO
OPPOSE THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AIBO.
WE LIKE THE ROLE TO BE ALL OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
OKAY THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE THAT.
COOPER'S.
THIS RULE WAS OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ONLY.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE A
FIFTY FOUR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
I'M.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TELLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS EAT.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEMS ELEVEN THROUGH FOURTEEN
PASS AND RETAIN.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY FEBRUARY NINTH NO
FLOOR SESSION NOTE CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED A MORE NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE CLEAR THE
CHAMBERS ARE TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR
THE IN GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE CLEAR THE
CHAMBER.
HER PLEASE FOCUS YOUR ATTENTION.
ON THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I ASKED WE RIDE
THAT WE SEE.
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
A CONSTITUENT. AND A TREASURED
LOCAL METEOROLOGIST JIM BERNARD.
JIM BERNARD WAS EASILY ONE OF
THE MOST VISIBLE PEOPLE AND
HUMBOLDT AND DON'T ARE COUNTIES.
HE BEGAN HIS BROADCASTING CAREER
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHT
K. V. I. Q. TV IN EUREKA.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX THE MOVE
TO QUE AYE E. M. TV AND AFTER
TWENTY FIVE DISTINGUISHED YEARS
AS AN ON AIR METEOROLOGIST. HE
FINALLY RETIRED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE.
GYMS COMMITMENT TO HIS COMMUNITY
INCLUDED IS TENURE ON THE
TRINIDAD CITY COUNCIL FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE TO NINETEEN
NINETY TWO. AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DONOR COUNTY REGIONAL AIRPORT
FROM TWO THOUSAND FIVE TO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
JIM BERNARD PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY TWENTY THIRD TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HE WAS SIXTY
FOUR YEARS OLD.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE CHRIS
IS CHILDREN JEFF AND LACY. I ASK
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ADJOURNED
IN THE MEMORY OF JIM BERNARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF SCULPTURE CERAMICIST
AND STORY TELLER. DORIS DE LAGOS
BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
THE MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS STILL
ADIOS GREW UP IN BOYLE HEIGHTS A
MULTI MULTI CULTURAL
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH THRIVING
MEXICAN AMERICAN JAPANESE
AMERICAN AND JEWISH AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
AT THE AGE OF SIX TO LAURIE US
HAVE A TRANSFORMATIVE EXPERIENCE
WHEN VISITING THE NATIONAL
MUSEUM OF ANTHROPOLOGY IN MEXICO
CITY WHERE SHE WAS ESPECIALLY
INSPIRED. BY AN ANCIENT AZTEC
CALENDAR IT WAS AT THAT POINT
THAT SHE KNEW SHE WANTED TO BE
AN ARTIST A CALLING SHE WOULD
WHOLEHEARTEDLY PURSUE. FOR OVER
SIX DECADES.
THE LAUREUS GRADUATED FROM U. S.
C. WITH A DEGREE IN CERAMICS IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND SET UP
AN INDEPENDENT STUDIO IN LOS
ANGELES.
HER WORK HAD A CLEAR VISION
INSPIRED BY PRE COLUMBIAN AN
ANCIENT JAPANESE ART. OVER THE
COURSE OF HER LIFE HILARIOUS
WORKED ON MANY NOTABLE PROJECTS
AND PIECES OF PUBLIC ART. THAT
YOU CAN SEE THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES AND AS FAR AWAY AS
FLORIDA AND JAPAN.
ACCORDING TO OUR DAUGHTER
DELIRIOUS OFTEN SAID. I WANT TO
WORK UNTIL I PLOTS.
OF TRANSLATE LATER FOR IF YOU
NEED THAT.
AND SHE DID EXACTLY THAT WORKING
UP UNTIL HER DEATH.
EVEN WHILE FIGHTING OVARIAN
CANCER.
TO LEARN THIS PAST WINTER CLOVER
CITY HOME AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
FOUR ON SUNDAY JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH AND IS SURVIVED BY HER
DAUGHTER SABRINA. SON IN LAW
AARON AND GRANDCHILDREN WHO ME
AND MOST
AND I ASK THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK TO
BE ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
RUTH BANCROFT A RESIDENT OF
WALNUT CREEK WHO PASSED AWAY
NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTH OF LAST
YEAR AT THE AGE OF THE ONE
HUNDRED AND NINE.
RUTH WAS BORN ON SEPTEMBER
SECOND IN NINETEEN OH EIGHT IN
BOSTON MASSACHUSETTS BUT HER
FAMILY MOVED CALIFORNIA WHEN SHE
WAS JUST A BABY.
AND SAY THEY CAME AND SETTLED IN
THE CALIFORNIA AREA AND LEFT A
LEGACY IN THE EAST BAY AND.
NOT JUST WANNA CREEK FOR
GENERATIONS.
SHE HAD A FASCINATION WITH
NATURE AND HORTICULTURE THAT
DATES ALL THE WAY BACK TO HER
CHILDHOOD AND THAT'S HOW SHE HAS
LEFT A GREAT MARK ON OUR
COMMUNITY. IN THE WANNA CREEK
AREA SHE AND HER HUSBAND PHILLIP
FOUNDED THE BANCROFT GARDENS THE
RUTH BANCROFT GARDENS. IT
STARTED FROM HER OWN PERSONAL
SELECTION OF COLLECTION OF
SUCCULENT PLANTS AND TREES AND
OTHER TYPES OF PLANTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE
RESISTANT.
TO DROUGHT AND.
STRESS CONDITIONS IN GARDENING
AND EXPANDED TO A TWO ACRE PARK
IN THE WALNUT CREEK AREA THIS IS
ONE WHERE. I AM HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF SCHOOL CHILDREN AND
LITERALLY GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE COME TO VISIT
AND LEARN HORTICULTURE IN THE
SCIENCE.
AND THAT WAS PARTICULARLY A BUSY
AREA DURING THE A DROUGHT THAT
WE HAD BECAUSE MANY VISITORS
HAVE COME TO THE ROOF BANCROFT
GARDEN.
RUTH IS SURVIVED BY A WONDERFUL
FAMILY THAT HAS BEEN IN THE
WATER CREEK AREA FOR MANY YEARS.
INCLUDING HER CHILDREN PETER
BANCROFT NEEDED DICKERSON AND
KATHY HIDALGO AND FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN.
I'M A I OFFER ON BEHALF OF OUR
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN THE STATE
OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO
RICH'S FAMILY AND DEEP DEEP
GRATITUDE FOR HER EFFECT ON
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
THINK YOU MEMBERS FOR JOINING IN
HER MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES OF THE DUST TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO RETURN A MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER BONTA MOVES AND MISS
BAKER SECONDS ABOUT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
FEBRUARY NINTH AT ONE PM THE
QUORUM CALL WAS LIFTED